And you don't even notice
the box that you're in,
until someone comes along
and lets you out.
-Can I help you?
-Hey.
Thanks.
-Where's Luther?
-Who cares?
Probably out for a run.
Love the haircut.
So, I… I talked
to Marcus last night.
Wait, what? You talked
with the enemy by yourself?
Yeah, well, somebody
had to do something.
Who elected you, Vanya?
It's Viktor.
Who's Viktor?
I am.
It's who I've always been.
Is that an issue for anyone?
Nah, I'm good with it.
Yeah, me too.
Cool.
Truly happy for you, Viktor.
You know,
I always hated mirrors.
Thought everybody felt
so strange in their skin.
I guess,
that's not true, right?
What do you see now?
Me.
Just me.
Thank you
for trusting me with this.
You're family, Viktor.
Okay?
And there's nothing…
nothing that would
make me love you less.
Hey. What's up?
Luther wants to throw you
a big stupid party
so you can feel loved.
-Oh.
-Do you feel loved?
Yeah, I… I do.
Good. You are.
Can we all get back
to saving the world now?
I…
I really like the hair.
It's a number ten?
Yeah, that's a good choice.
Really… frames your face.
Thanks.
I'll see you later.